こんにちは
1ヶ月あれば必ず誰でも1億円稼げる方法をみなさんに寄せます
起業家の肇社長ですよろしくお願いします
嘘です皆さんこんにちははじめ社長ですよね
あの今日ちょっとこの後東京でですね別の撮影があるんですスーツ一応スーツでスーツ
のちょっとキレイバージョンなお洒落な格好をしているんですけどもそう今日だけがご
了承下さいませんそそう
今の話にも出たんですけども東京ちょっと前にあのアンケート
皆さんに決めてほしいもう無理すぎて決めてほしいっていうん
けどとって僕この先どこに引っ越す住むばいいのかというアンケートを取りました
一応候補が2つありましてと静岡東京で米だね静岡の東京てやって大表数の多かった
ところに引っ越しますそこにすみますっていうアンケートをとったんですけども
2月いっぱいまで投票しますと言われたんですけどもう最近で投票数が変動しなくなっ
たんでもう
締め切っちゃってどっちにするか発表したいと思いますまずですね投票数を見る前に
ですねどういうコメントがついているか見てみましょう
まずですね投票に行くできって人のコメントを見てみましょうッピー前変なおじさんが
段階も来てるんですよね僕はそれが心配ですああなるほど
もう家が特定低下夢中でちゃってるんですよねちょっと切っちゃうんですよ
まあでも貼れて
十分ですね超監視カメラを複数台設置してるんでまぁそこは大丈夫だと思います
遅かれ早かれいずれいかなきゃいけんだけど右が来ると思う
それは間違いないですねあたけがもっとなんか人気出ると多分絶対東京に行かなきゃ
いけない気が
いつかは来ると思いますまだまだ大丈夫だと思う大阪なんでや
静岡に行っても始め様結局頑張って目利用して動画を開けて用としてくれると思います
でもそれじゃあ体壊れちゃいます東京に来て自分のペースで動画を上げてくれませんが
あなたの方が一番大切ですよ
ありがとうございます嬉しいですねこういうコメントは実際東京行くときは必ず寝不足
ですから無理したくないけど最近でそんな無理に毎日行ったそうともしてないからねた
時もあるし自分のペースで最近痩せていただいております投票行って動画が増えるなが
全然東京のほうがいい
確かにねそれはあるねあ調合前に住んでほしいです
きりたんぽさん偽物でしょ武田東京ネット結構なんか理論派の人が多いですね
静岡の誇りって言ってるけど東金買ったら普通の一般人だし始めは動画を出したこと
ユーチューバーぜひ取りやすい環境東京へ
うんありがとうございますまあ間違いないですそれで僕も迷ってるんで一周回って秋田
を放って厚木市
静岡見ていきましょう静岡のコメントはネジ増加が大好きな静岡に住むのが一番じゃ
ないですね
決めからね迷ってるんだよね好きじゃなかったらもうすぐ東京行きますから
東京だと動画ないよ制限されるしすぐに家特定されそうまあ確かにねこの家は何か何で
もしていいイージー大家さんとも仲良いんでなんかもうハチャメチャを知ってますけど
東京にこれで同じ物件があるかっていうとないと思うんですよね確かって言え的に静岡
方が良いんじゃ確かにそれは発言ねこんな面白い建物ねすごいよね構造が実はでうち3
階建てなんですよね今と同じ得て撮影して下さいどうかが3日に1回くらいでもそっち
の方が良くないっていう頃の意見静岡でしかできないこの家でしかできないことが多い
ですからね
僕のコメントを見ました見ました愛と
いうわけでですねまぁいろんなコメントこうやって見てきたわけなんですけどもまぁ
結局ですね
これ見たところで僕の意見は変わってないんですよピグ皆さんに決めてもらうとも言っ
てるんで見たやふーんと思ってるだけでおまかせであれなんですけど皆さんの好評で
どっちに住むか決めようと思います発表いたします
good 数
14000表たい
46,000表デー
教えドーガー
ああああああああ
圧倒的ですね4万6000台14000もう
ダブルス個以上で静岡だったんだよそれはもう23日待っても変わんなかったと思い
ます結果
というわけでですねっと皆さんの意見を踏まえて
静岡にわからないですとりあえず今年いっぱいは絶対いますけれどもこの先は分からん
ですもう忙しすぎて全く動画日につかなくなってくるとかなるとまずで絶対東京に
引っ越しますし東京が東京付近かな
現状ですねまぁてつだってくれる仲間とかね仕事仲間もたくさんいるんでとりあえずは
静岡でやっていこうかなと思いますマッチ
買えないしこんな素晴らしいいえこんな素晴らしい大家さんこんな素晴らしい仲間立つ
囲まれている環境は静岡にしかないと思うのでもうちょっとしぞーか楽しんでいこうか
なと思いますから東京に引っ越した方がいいって言ってくださった方結構いたし
コメント意見がねまつげなく正論なんで全然僕が東京に引っ越すことも踏まえながら
いるんでまぁでも今じゃないのかなという気はし
おりますと言うけど始めたと引き続き静岡で頑張って行きたいと思います余談ですが私
は事務所静岡県議会選挙のメインキャラクターを務めさせていただきます
よろしくお願いした静岡られ
いいいい
ええええええ
あっ